we bring in the Hall of Famer the
playmaker he is Michael Irvin hey feelin
today Mike what's up man I'm a little
banged up my voice is banged up my
body's banged up I went running around
the field yesterday and at 25 backwards
I just can't do that anymore that was an
incredible incredible game okay why are
you all banged up like were you out of
your mind last night in the roller
coaster you know we had that Monday
night game a couple weeks ago was great
you know it was great but but that game
last night was great and I mean I was
out of my freakin mind I went every play
it was I've never seen I don't think
I've ever seen a defensive performance
like that ever let alone saying it's the
best one I've seen from the Dallas
Cowboys when we think about what that
team was doing what the wall has had
been doing all to everybody been
watching everybody and then to come out
and Dallas to play that kind of a game
to give themselves a chance when what's
just flat-out
it was flat-out incredible man so yeah I
went running along then I was shaking
everybody's hands slapping hands on
understand and I think I might have
broken a couple those people and because
they look like they started pulling back
like no we don't want you touching our
hands anymore Michael but I was just so
high man it was an incredible game okay
are you looking at this team now as a
more defensive team or are they still an
offensive team in your mind well when
you put on that kind of a performance on
defense right now in a week that we're
talking about where is the defense you
know Dallas put up and said hey they
raised their hand and said we're the
best people in the NFL I I wanna tell
anybody show me anybody see a better
defensive game this year in the game you
saw last night from the Dallas Cowboys
so hey right now as young as they are on
our
they're very young or defense to I will
say right now the catalyst for this team
is thesis but it still has to go to Z
Kelly you know they still have to be
able to run the ball and they did that
last night so hold on time of possession
now if you let drew brees get you a time
of possession he has the ball 3035
minutes
I don't you out there that defense is
he's going to find a way to get to the
end zone but the time of possession was
like 37 223 last night and favored a
Dallas so it was a combination of both
of those AA squad playing together yeah
but now it looks like and it feels like
the expectation level just went through
the roof that now it's Super Bowl or
bust for this Dallas team is that a fair
expectation level it's always high
expectations quickly high expectation
with the Cowboys in it and absolutely
that I believe that's fair you know you
bring in Amari Cooper and I said this
last night then Amari Cooper got you to
the top of the division that game last
night you play in this game last night
this game that game got you to the top
of the conference because everybody I'm
sure everybody on your show because
everybody on there be on this show head
this head the Saints as the top team in
the NFL especially after they beat the
Rams and in the Cowboys win and beat the
Saints so that puts Tempe a date they
should have those kinds of expectations
what's your biggest concern with the
Cowboys moving forward you know and the
growth that they still need theater
couple plays you know the fact that you
can't like you can't fumble that ball
and that spot later in the game you
gotta at least go get three and put put
me through get seven points and then
maybe that play down the sideline to
Michael Dallas man you got you make that
play and we're talking from an offensive
standpoint that they fill the game
offensively but but I love the fact that
they came out and filled it defensively
against bad team against the st. where
everybody's
talking about trees and he looked and he
still lists it's just you know last
night wasn't his night we drew brees is
playing the best quarterback that we may
have ever seen at the quarterback
position until he ran into them boys
last night he ran into those boys are
you all in on dak Prescott yeah I am I
am all in all that Prescott what we have
is we have this microwave NFL now when
we expect guys to come in and play great
right now right now you know I'm still
up the old school where it takes three
to four years before these guys really
hit their stride but since we've had
that success with changing of these
offenses and make it a more palatable
for these young guys we're expecting the
microwave system of guys becoming great
right away so yeah dad have some
improvement to do to be doing but but I
am all in all that Prescott I love this
q all right rest your voice rest your
body you know it's you got a you're
gonna take it one game at a time all
right
[Laughter]
it's not going well I feel for
everything out there buddy
because now that's all you can do is
real fan and you got a rider to you so
you could do thank you Mike good to talk
to you
DP is good to talk to your man tell
everybody all the family and everybody I
said happy holidays Manny ain't your
daddy but Michael Irvin the playmaker
for more Dan Patrick show to the
audience Channel 239 on DirecTV or
download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]